black ops is a series known for
outlandish alternate history and boy has
it gone places at times
from the numbers mason to rock videos
here are seven of the wildest things
that happen
both in and around the black ops series
number one mind within mind control as
various characters in the black ops
series
you as the player have been mind
controlled quite a lot you were mind
controlled to kill the us
president deemed a mind control failure
and were remind controlled by victor
reznoff to carry out his personal
vendettas
in black ops 3 you play as a mind
control future soldier
so mind controlled you literally just
refer to yourself as
player and don't know who you are or
what's even real
my mind hurts number two that time you
didn't kill kennedy but
maybe you did in black ops 1 there's a
scene where you're talking to president
jfk
and the numbers come up pressing you to
kill him but you resist
or did you when you're drowning
dragovich at the end of the game you say
you tried to make me kill my own
president his response is
later you're seen in a hazy memory near
kennedy as he gets off a plane
this scene just might be dragovich
messing with mason's mind but
what do you think number 3
woods shoots mason black ops 2 had a
branching storyline with alternate
endings which was pretty cool
in one part of the campaign players in
the role of woods chilling with manuel
noriega by the way
are asked to shoot a hooded captive the
captive turned out to be alex mason
the main character from the first black
ops game a lot of you bloodthirsty
savages killed him
alternatively some sharp-eyed folks
noticed the prisoner whose face was
covered
was wearing mason's clothes not
menendez's
so what'd they do shoot him in the leg
doing this gives you the family reunion
achievement and slightly changes the
ending of the game
either way woods ends up raising mason's
kid david and lying about what happened
but if you don't shoot alex in the head
he will show up at the ending and they
will have a colorful reunion with both
woods and david
dave how you doing this is your dad
side note that this ending here is canon
number four avenged sevenfold's carry-on
music video
black ops 2 had some really dark endings
and when all was said and done
and cortes d may or may not have totally
destroyed modern civilization woods and
menendez put their differences aside
to make a music video seriously
fernandez what the [ __ ] are you doing
woods on drums of course because
apparently he never needed his
wheelchair
i'm ready to roll baby what the [ __ ]
nah i'm just crazy let's go kill this
thing
rob double time that means you menendez
number five the end of black ops three
like
all of it talking forest muted
characters
ai murder god siblings zombies burning
heart metaphors
seriously ask around nobody really knows
or agrees what the hell happened at the
end of black ops 3
do you have any idea no
for starters you get de-limbed and
placed in a coma and are probably living
someone else's memories the entire time
it's unclear whose memories the player
is living at at any given moment
the person or person's memories are
often faulty unreliable or just plain
false
a computer virus is infecting the player
all along corrupting their sanity and
probably making them see
some people as other people there's so
much noise
in my head i can't even think there's
this frozen forest which other than
being a premium asmr experience
silences main characters as they
desperately try to tell you the plot
so yeah let's just all slowly back away
from this
entry in the series except for
multiplayer
number six that time you killed castro
for a second
in call of duty block ops first mission
they just get right into it and you kill
fidel castro max payne style
it isn't until the end of the mission
that you find out you killed his stunt
double
it's a good thing too because castro
goes on to help you fight the zombies
later on
i mean this is off canon right do not
pray for easy lives my friends
pray to be stronger men
number seven activision gets sued the
opening of black ops 2
showed a rebel leader wielding a grenade
launcher and spurring his forces on to
mow down enemy soldiers
it made for a pretty memorable opening
but it turns out the man was a real-life
military leader named jonas zavimby
who actually died in battle his family
sued activision for one million euro for
depicting their father as a barbarian
wanting to kill
everybody believe it or not activision
was also sued by manuel noriega
but the case was dismissed with call of
duty cold war coming up there will
probably be plenty more wild moments in
alternate history to look forward to
what other wild black ops moments can
you think of let us know in the comments
below
also don't forget to check out
gamespot's online store where you can
pick up masks amongst
other handy items thanks for watching
[Applause]
[Music]
you